est-ce que c'est par rapport à l'âge
j'ai pensé à geneviève de fontenay
maintenant ce sont des questions qui
n'ont des réponses que par oui ou par
non pour l'invité directement et pour y
arriver là pour un invité êtes vous une
femme
ça une femme que pour un homme oui voilà
oui et pour un non marley de jean michel
maire non ah merde
votre voix et maquillés
[Applaudissements]
votre question daniel la suite à une
question est ce que vous êtes l'ex d'un
des hommes sur le plateau avec moi
question
sa valeur donc c'est pas nécessairement
donc voilà un nex tout ça est ce que
vous êtes donc une amie proche de gilles
verdez non non non non pas que je
propose parce que j'en connais on est en
train de ramer un petit peu un premier
rang disent oui à vous aider je vois que
vous vous êtes dans la semoule là comme
un indice
avec une canne donc c'est pour une
personne âgée c'est pour une personne
âgée
a troqué son jean michel est-ce que vous
avez des poils sous les bras
comme ça oui est ce que vivent ou de la
famille de quelqu'un oui
c'est un membre de la famille d'un des
garçons de ce plateau dont c'est
jean-michel non non non non et mille
îles et jean-michel et la soeur de
quelqu'un de sûr le plateau est ce que
vous êtes la soeur de quelqu'un qui est
sur ce plateau non non plus on a dix
personnages et donc ma maman souhaite la
maman la fille de gilles verdez nom
alors je alors est ce qu'on peut avoir
notre à nice alors 2 heures 10
[Musique]
il est sûr que vous avez été la nounou
d'un des garçons
assez bien
la pensée est ce que vous dites du poil
aux jambes
comme chez vous n'hésitez pas à jouer et
nous dire d'un président estime qu'il
s'agit oui mag avait longtemps que vous
avez pas vu la personne concernée n'ont
pas longtemps oui sks que vous la voyez
tous les jours non à tous les jours
d'accord c'est pas possible est ce que
c'est vous qui êtes âgé parce qu'on a vu
une personne âgée avec une canne est ce
que c'est vous qui avez quand même un
certain non non c'est la personne est ce
que c'est la personne sur ce plateau qui
est âgée
est la maîtresse de quelques
[Rires]
mois faire un peu les pièces on a on a
éliminé les filles d'après vous quels
étaient les le garçon qu'elle est le
garçon qui n'est concerné parce que
je pense avoir jamais et pourquoi ça
tombe sur moi tout va bien y avait un
vécu sur les sables beaucoup plus
important
ce n'est pas une mais trop n'ai aucune
idée benjamin vous n'êtes pas une ex à
moi non mais la ville a permis jamaïque
ont regardé les indices futures at war
je crois que je les attends je crois que
j'ai les jeux faits ou pas non non oui
je peux ou pas les insultes c'est à bruz
et sa belle fille mabelle vie parce que
c'est un vieux c'est un papy mais oui
elle est belle et charles avait laissé
son bébé
ça oui c'est ça c'est ça ça peut être
mal c est là bas qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ça
on peut voir si c'est exactement elle
jean-michel mystère si qui êtes-vous
invité mystère est ce que c'est henry
elle va arriver en plateau lundi
[Applaudissements]
là
mais où
m
lundi c'était parce que ça
te disais tu vas être
[Rires]
pas trop si c'est votre bruay fait oui
lui ni moi n'avions pas encore mariés
vous auriez dû cette année on aurait dû
s'il n'avait pas eu le pied c'est
d'abord la lah avec la robe un peu trop
voilà tu faire des essayages tous les
mois
est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
benjamin va être un bon grand-père
j'ai dit que cette enfance avec les
dernières années qu'on passe ensemble je
suis persuadé un truc marrant c'est que
m'a fait la surprise ça va c'est un
garçon une fille née en moi qui n'ai
fait que des garçons je rêvais ajouté
vous parce que l'image est belle
dans la lumière qui nous aident dans
l'ombre et dans l'animal où je rêvais
d'avoir une petite fille donc évident
alors quand ils ont fait le ballon avec
les que j'ai vu les deux oui et quand
j'ai vu que c'était aux noms
comme un petit gars fatigué ça m'allait
très bien il est en bonne santé et bien
d'accord donc ce sera un petit b un
petit bébé castaldi
autre scoop on n'était que mon père pour
l'anniversaire de nos deux garçons tendo
et ils vont trouver le prénom oui mais
est-ce qu'on peut le dire le prénom
c'est moi qui le dis cette fois ci
on peut le dire ou pas julien
98%
la maman félicita les la mer
normalement on l'appellera angelo
nous appellerons dit on se connaît
depuis 25 ans honnêtement qu'est ce que
ça te fait je veux plutôt à la baleine
dans un petit moment d'émotion parce que
je sais que tu t'es arrivé tu m'as dit
non mais tu vas pas savoir mais ça y est
je suis grand père c'est pas possible
qu'est ce que ça t'a fait quand julien
et kiara sens du terroir il se dira pas
beaucoup plus parce que je m'étais dit
waouh c'est un peu tôt va pas se monter
un peu plus mon jeune âge 15
mai différence entre mon père et un à
ronan la même différence entre toi et
moi et ma là il a fait comme une vache à
lait c'est ça
qui est bien c'est que mon fils va être
en fait l'oncle de mon petit-fils
musique ah ouais bah oui ah bah oui
parce que le teen movie nyala gabriel
c'est bien pour les économies d'échelle
par rapport à nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à rester rester